probability models often involve
infinite sample spaces that is infinite
sets but not all sets are of the same
kind some sets are discrete and we call
them countable and some are continues
and we call them uncountable
but what exactly is the difference
between these two types of sets how can
we define it precisely well let us start
by first giving a definition of what it
means to have a countable set a set will
be called countable if its elements can
be put into a one-to-one correspondence
with the positive integers this means
that we look at the elements of that set
and we take one element we call it the
first element we take another element we
call it the second another we call the
third element and so on and this way we
will eventually exhaust all of the
elements of the set so that each one of
those elements corresponds to a
particular positive integer namely the
index that appears underneath more
formally what's happening is that we
take elements of that set that are
arranged in a sequence we look at the
set which is the entire range of values
of that sequence and we want that
sequence to exhaust the entire set Omega
or in other words in simpler terms we
want to be able to arrange all the
elements of Omega in a sequence so what
are some examples of countable sets in a
trivial sense the positive integers
themselves are countable because we can
arrange them in a sequence this is
almost tautological by the definition
for a more interesting example let's
look at the set of all integers can we
arrange them in a sequence yes we can
and we can do it in this manner where we
alternate between positive and negative
numbers
and this way we're going to cover all
the integers and we have arranged them
in a sequence how about the set of all
pairs of positive integers this is less
clear let us look at this picture this
is the set of all pairs of positive
integers which we understand to continue
indefinitely can we arrange this set in
a sequence it turns out that we can and
we can do it by tracing a path of this
kind so you can probably get the sense
of how this path is going and by
continuing this way over and over we're
going to cover the entire set of all
pairs of positive integers so we have
managed to arrange them in a sequence so
the set of all such pairs is indeed a
countable set and the same argument can
be extended to argue for the set of all
triples of positive integers or the set
of called quadruples of positive
integers and so on this is actually not
just trivial mathematical point that we
discuss for some curious reason but it
is because we will often have sample
spaces that are of this kind and it's
important to know that they are
countable now for a more subtle example
let us look at all rational numbers
within the range between 0 & 1 what do
we mean by rational numbers we mean
those numbers that can be expressed as a
ratio of two integers it turns out that
we can arrange them in a sequence and we
can do it as follows
let us first look at rational numbers
that have a denominator term of two then
look at the rational numbers that have a
denominator term of three then look at
the rational numbers always within this
range of interest that have a
denominator of four
and then we continue similarly rational
numbers that have a denominator of 5 and
so on this way we're going to exhaust
all the rational numbers actually this
number here already appeared there it's
the same number so we do not need to
include this in a sequence but that's
not an issue whenever we see in rational
numbers that has already been
encountered before we just delete it in
the end we end up with a sequence that
goes over all the possible rational
numbers and so we conclude that the set
of all rational numbers is itself a
countable set so what kind of set would
be uncountable
an uncountable set by definition is a
set that is not countable and there are
examples of uncountable sets most
prominent continues subsets of the real
line whenever we have an interval the
unit interval or any other interval that
has positive lengths that interval is an
uncountable set and the same is true if
instead of an interval we look at the
entire real line or we look at the
two-dimensional plane or 3 dimensional
space and so on so all the usual sets
that we think of as continuous sets turn
out to be uncountable how do we know
that they're uncountable there is
actually a brilliant argument that
establishes that the unit interval is
uncountable and then the argument is
easily extended to other cases like the
reals and the plain we do not need to
know how this argument goes for the
purposes of this course but just because
it is so beautiful we will actually be
presenting it to you